en parís el martes por la noche y los
manifestantes expresaron su apoyo a un
convoy de la libertad europeo como el de
canadá
la idea es venir y bloquear partes clave
de parís como han hecho los canadienses
y quedarse allí steitz exigimos libertad
y verdad y el fin de todas las
restricciones sanitarias la mejor
sanidad el principal grupo de protesta
en las redes sociales tiene alrededor de
300.000 miembros y está creciendo
rápidamente
planean llegar a la capital desde toda
francia aunque los organizadores son
conscientes de que no podrán movilizar
miles de camiones es duro clásica habrá
automóviles y motos normalmente pero
será más difícil movilizar camiones
porque en francia la mayoría de los
conductores no son dueños de sus
vehículos
el movimiento reúne tanto a los chalecos
amarillos como a los manifestantes anti
vacunas
es una especie de torre de babel donde
cada uno tiene sus propias demandas
habrá que ver si forman un todo
coherente
con las protestas de los chalecos
amarillos que comenzaron en 2018 vieron
a miles de personas manifestarse en
ciudades de todo el país cada fin de
semana al gobierno le tomó meses calmar
la situación con concesiones y sólo se
agotaron con el primer confinamiento por
la pandemia
recientemente los manifestantes anti
vacunas están en el centro del escenario
100.000 de ellos se manifestaron en
francia durante uno de los fines de
semana de enero pero no han ganado mucho
terreno como el que tuvieron los
chalecos amarillos